if you're staying home it's going to be
busy out on the strip and downtown
that's right well las vegas is now jc
fernandez joining us now with an
entertainment roundup
memorial day means big crowds and some
of the biggest lineups all across our
clubs and venues around town and here's
a look at who's in town this weekend wet
republic kicks off memorial day weekend
with performances from steve aoki martin
garrix cascade and lil john
encore beach club continues a
celebration tonight with kim lee david
guetta and the chain smokers dress opens
their lineup with meek mill tonight lil
wayne on saturday and little baby on
sunday elliott beach club is having a
fire day party with an artist lineup of
grammy award-winning artist chance the
rapper eric deluxe and edm favorites
lane 8 and elderbrook the newest beach
club in town tau starts their weekend
with alesso on saturday a special sunday
lineup with tyga lil john and bia and to
close off memorial day weekend jersey
shore star dj paulie d now there are a
few other big names in town including
the doobie brothers over at the zappos
theater and country superstar keith
urban will take over the coliseum at
caesar's palace pop sensation katy perry
she is back for her residency at resorts
world and finally british rock band
foghat hits the stage at the golden
nugget now downtown is not missing out
on the fun fremont street experiences
free concert series downtown rocks are
bringing back-to-back performances by
we have ex-ambassadors they're on
saturday night and starship featuring
mickey thompson is here on sunday and
that is your memorial day weekend lineup